>>Male Presenter: OK, hello everybody.
Thank you for coming.
And for waiting.
We're here with the director of "Brave."
The new Disney Pixar movie.
It's terrific I saw it yesterday.
Mark Andrews, thanks so much for joining us.
[applause]
>>Mark: Hi.
Hi.
>>Male Presenter: And you're a long time animation
veteran.
Worked as a story supervisor of "The Incredibles."
Worked on the story for "Iron Giant."
For a couple of the Pixar shorts "One Man
Band" and "Jack-Jack Attack" which are really
hilarious.
So it's just an honor to have you here at
Google and thanks again so much for coming.
My name's Ryan.
I don't know if anybody cares but I lead the
Google doodle team and we're all Pixar sycophants
on the team.
And we love everything that you guys do.
>>Mark: [laughing]
>>Male Presenter: And again, it's an honor
to have some time to talk with you.
>>Mark: Great.
Great.
>>Male Presenter: So, I realized you also
use some Google products yourself.
You have a blogspot blog?
>>mark: Uh-huh.
>>Male Presenter: And it's mostly pictures
of you sword fighting.
>>Mark: Uh-huh.
>>Male Presenter: And videos of you sword
fighting.
And so, you sign your name "Mandrews" on your
blog posts.
Is that, do people call you Mandrews inside
of the Pixar universe.
>>Mark: Yes.
Yes.
That's just my you know when you get to Pixar
you get your email things.
So it's just you know, M. Andrews and it just
turned out to be Mandrews.
So it just kinda stuck.
So now I'm Mandrews.
>>Male Presenter: That's good, that's awesome.
And so if people need to email you
>>Mark: They just say Mandrews.
>>Male Presenter: Mandrews.
Awesome.
And then I read that you didn't originally
plan to be in animation.
Can you kinda give us a little of your epic
journey and how you ended up in, not just
the industry, but in one of the most coveted
and storied traditions in all of history.
>>Mark: Ooops.
Ah.
I've been drawing all my life.
You know, ever since I was three.
My dad worked in Lenwood, California.
He was a schoolteacher and counselor and dean
of the high school there.
And computers were just coming out.
So he would bring home the reams of the white
and green computer paper.
'Cause they would only print whatever numbers
on one side, so he'd bring home stacks of
this stuff for me.
That was just folded, you know.
Reams of it.
And I would just draw on it and draw on the
opposite side.
So I've been drawing all my life and did high
school and stuff.
I'm not ambitious.
I didn't have any aspirations to do anything.
I didn't know what I was gonna do after high
school.
I just drew.
I was gonna be a Marine after high School.
All my friends were goin' in the armed services.
My best friend's in the Navy.
I have other friends who were in the Marines.
>>Male Presenter: That explains some of the
sword fighting.
>>Mark: Yes.
Well I've been doing martial arts all my life.
And sword fighting.
And so out of high school, I didn't take any
college prep classes or nothin'.
So high school ends, and I'm all "What do
I do now?"
So I'm talking to a Marine Recruiter.
I'm not ready to go right into the Marines
right then and there.
So I'm all "Ahh, well, City College I guess."
So I went to City College and that's where
I got my first formal training as an artist
and life drawing, perspective, and just drawing.
Which was more like rendering.
You know, crosshatching.
And I did two years of City College.
And this was all in Santa Barbara.
And one class, one semester this guy was offering
this animation course.
And I'd been into Japanese animation my whole
life.
You know, Kimba the White Lion, Speed Racer,
Star Blazers, RoboTech.
You know all this stuff.
Akira had come out when I was graduating high
school and I was just "Whoa, this is amazing!"
So I'm doing animation class and I'm doing
my own kind of anime type stuff that's just
ultraviolent.
You know.
Fun thing.
And he tells me, the instructor tells me about
Cal Arts, which is up in Valencia.
California Institute of the Arts.
And I'm all, "You can actually do this for
a living?
Wow.
I better apply."
So me and my brother applied at Cal Arts and
we got in and I remember calling my recruiter
the Marine Recruiter and saying "Sorry man,
I'm goin' to art school."
So, he was kind of upset.
[laughter]
So I did four years of Cal Arts and got my
degree in film.
Whoopee.
And got out and starved for a year.
>>Male presenter: Yeah.
What was starving like for you?
How did that
>>Mark: oh, it was fun.
It was livin' off a credit card and eating
potato chips and hot dogs.
That's it.
That was the cheapest food I could find that
was kinda substantial.
I couldn't do ramen every day.
>>Male Presenter: Even though you had a predisposition
for Japanese culture.
>>Mark: Yes, yes.
But not a predisposition for Japanese food.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
Yeah.
>>Mark: I like things that are cooked.
So, all my friends got jobs in the animation
industry and I was the only one who didn't.
I went to the Disney internship right out
of school.
I was the only one out of five who didn't
get fired because I rocked the boat.
>>Male Presenter: I read about that.
And I'm kind of curious.
I mean, like, how did you rock the boat?
I mean, were you a punk?
Or were you
>>Mark: They.
No.
I was just being me.
>>Male Presenter: Was it the hot dogs?
>>Mark: It was the hot dogs.
I was just me, and at the end of the internship
they want you to kind of do a presentation,
right?
That this is what I wanna do.
And they were really looking.
I mean this was the hype.
They were animating Lion King when I was there.
And they were rolling out Pocahontas and Hunchback
of Notre Dame and all these things were just
comin' off of Beauty and the Beast.
So it's startin' to go up.
And DreamWorks is just being created at this
time.
So this was like Golden Age of animation.
So they wanted animators 'cause they didn't
have enough.
And I could animate.
But what I was really falling in love with
was story boarding.
So I was the only one out of five interns
who presented two presentations.
And because I presented two presentations,
one in animation and one on story, they don't
like to make a decision at Disney.
And that's rockin' the boat.
So they came in and looked at it.
And I thought you know, you guys pick.
Either or.
I'm happy.
But they couldn't.
And that just totally threw them and so I
was the only one who didn't get hired.
And then I was blacklisted at Disney.
And they wouldn't hire me.
>>Male Presenter: I mean it sounds like, I
mean blacklisted seems like you would have
to have punched somebody named Disney in the
face.
>>Mark: Yeah.
I don't know.
I was automatically branded a rabble rouser
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
That's like
>>Mark: For doing two presentations.
You know, and then I went off and starved
for a year.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: And then I got into TV animation.
I was working at Hanna Barbara.
Well, I went back to Cal Arts where I was
teaching a sword fighting class and fencing.
To make some money to eat and live.
And then I got a job on TV.
>>Male Presenter: So Disney now, I mean obviously
as Pixar is part of the Disney family
>>Mark: Yup
>>Male Presenter: Are there people in the
hallway you've gotta like avert eyes with
because they were
>>Mark: All those people are gone.
>>Male Presenter: They're all gone?
>>Mark: Yeah.
Who blacklisted me.
They're all gone.
And I survived!
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: I would imagine, and how
much is sword fighting actually?
I mean that's a good survival skill.
I mean you know, even if things would
>>Mark: If zombies attack.
>>Male Presenter: Even if things really go
down.
>>Mark: I'm good.
>>Male Presenter: But in corporate, I mean,
the machinery of corporate.
>>Mark: It's like "The Book of the Five Rings."
You know.
You treat it like that.
Kind of you know.
Hit first.
>>Male Presenter: So, but then you went into
TV animation but then it's still like you're,
I would imagine that's starting from the ground
up.
Kind of bottom of the heap?
>>Mark: The good thing about the TV animation,
was you're turning around, you're doin' half
an hour episodes in like eight weeks.
So I have to story board a half an hour of
stuff in eight weeks.
So.
And you don't get to redo it.
You kinda do it and it goes off to Korea or
Japan to be animated and that's that.
And then it airs on TV.
So I did five episodes for "the New Adventures
of Johnny Quest."
Which is a great learning process because
you're just doin' it from your gut.
And then Warner Brothers' animation started
up because DreamWorks started up and it was
being successful.
So now everybody in Hollywood, all the studios
wanted their own animation business.
And they still kinda do.
So, I met a bunch of great people at Disney
who left Disney to start over at Warner Brothers.
Bill Perkins is one of them.
He was the art director on "Aladdin" and he's
fantastic.
So I got to know him with my friends who were
working at Disney.
You know, of the internship.
And he went over to Warner Brothers and called
me and my brother.
And says "Come on over here, guys.
This is going to be wildly different."
So we went over there and got hired with Warner
Brothers and then started doing "Quest for
Camelot" which nobody ever saw.
So don't.
And then "Iron Giant" with Brad Bird.
And that's when I met Brad Bird for the first
time.
And then I stayed to do, I was head of story
on "Osmosis Jones."
And then I got called to work on the first
"Spiderman" movie with Sam Raimi.
>>Male Presenter: Wow.
>>Mark: And so I went into live-action storyboarding.
>>Male Presenter: What was that connection?
How did you get hooked up with that?
>>Mark: Jeff Lynch, who was my head of story
on "Iron Giant."
After "Iron Giant" was over, I'm doing "Osmosis
Jones" for the next two or something years.
He went on and Sam Raimi was starting up some
movies there at Warner Brothers.
So Jeff got hooked up with him and Jeff went
on to be his story board artist and second
unit director on "Simple Plan", "The Gift",
"For the love of the game", and then finally
they got, there was a whole Spiderman controversy.
Of what studio gets Spiderman.
And Sony came out on top after getting all
through the red tape.
So I'm at home workin' on my graphic novel
"Tales of Colossus" you guys can get on
>>Male Presenter: Blogspot.com
>>Mark: Yeah, blogspot.
You can check it out.
"Tales of Colossus" You can get on Amazon.
$14.99.
And, put my kids through school, please.
And so I'm sittin' there working on my comic,
my graphic novel.
And I get a phone call and I pick it up and
it's Jeff Lynch.
He's all "Hey, I want you to come down and
work on Spiderman."
I'm all "Totally, I'll be down tomorrow!"
He's all "Fantastic!"
I hang up the phone, I walk down the hallway,
I'm tellin' the truth.
I walk down the hallway to go back to my little
office and the phone rings again.
I'm all "Oh, it's Jeff telling me what gate
to go to at Sony."
>>Male Presenter: Mmm-hmmm
>>Mark: So I come back and pick it up and
it's "Hello?"
"Hey, Mark, it's Brad!"
"Hey Brad!"
Brad does the same exact imitation of me.
The exact
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Raspy voice?
>>Mark: Same raspy voice.
His imitation of me, my imitation of him is
identical.
So we don't sound like this.
"Hey Mark!
What's goin' on?"
I'm all "Brad, what's going' how's it up at
Pixar?"
'Cause he'd been, you know just started up
at Pixar.
He's all "How's the North Bay?"
He's all "Oh, man, I love it!
And you know what, I love it so much, I want
you to come up here and be head of story on
Incredibles."
I'm all "Totally, dude!
I'm totally, I'd totally come up!
I'd check in with my wife and we'd totally
move up there to work with you so, when do
you want me?"
He's all "Uh, kinda now."
I'm all "Uhhhhhhh, I kinda' accepted a job
already on Spiderman.
Do you really need me?"
He's all "What??"
I'm all "Jeff Lynch called me."
He's all "That, Jeff Lynch."
I'm all "So when do you need me?"
He's all "No worries, you got some time.
About nine months."
And I'm all "OK, great."
So I did back to back superhero movies.
I boarded on "Spiderman", boarded on most
of that movie.
And then I moved up north with my wife and
my newborn and started on "Incredibles."
>>Male Presenter: That sounds
>>Mark: And then been at Pixar ever since.
Twelve years.
So.
>>Male Presenter: That's incredible.
I'm a big fan of "Iron Giant."
That was just like a
>>Mark: Oh great.
>>Male Presenter: a beautiful, wonderful movie.
>>Mark: Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: and of course "Incredibles"
is one of my favorites from Pixar as well.
So you weren't a Disney guy, like dyed in
the wool.
Like you weren't, you didn't see "Pinocchio"
45 times.
>>Mark: No, no.
>>Male Presenter: And it wasn't your dream.
>>Mark: Nine old men?
Who?
I didn't care.
>>Male Presenter: and you were more actually
into the anime.
Japanese stuff.
What kinda' pulled you towards that as opposed
to the traditional or the resurgence of Disney
animation [inaudible]
>>Mark: Yeah.
Well, the.
I mean, I appreciate all that stuff.
I've seen all the Disney movies.
But to me as a kid, when I was a kid, cable
TV just started.
It was ON TV.
Anybody remember ON TV?
It was the first cable channel ever.
And they had three kinda stations.
And my uncle who was a professional bachelor,
he was married eight times like Henry the
Eighth.
He'd date.
Marriage was like dating to him.
But anyway.
He was the coolest guy ever.
Sports cars, and.
But he had ON TV, he had all the best.
And we would, my brother would look at the
TV Guide and see what was ON TV, and he's
all "Look, dude, the Apple Dumpling Gang is
on at eight o'clock.
But at the same time at ON Channel 3 is Mad
Max."
Which is rated R. And we're like 10 at the
time.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
No question there.
>>Mark: I'm all "Dude, we gotta go over."
So we would lie to our parents and lie to
my uncle and say "We wanna come over and watch
Apple Dumpling Gang" on TV.
And he'd go, “Yeah, sure.
Come on over.”
So my parents would drop us of.
He'd go off on some date.
>>Male Presenter: Like, hang gliding or something.
>>Mark: Yeah.
And we'd sit there and as soon as he'd leave.
Click!
And then we'd turn on Mad Max.
So I grew up on R rated movies when I was
a kid.
[laughs] So to watch Bambi or Sleeping Beauty
I'm like "Hoooo-huuum."
I mean, I appreciated the animation but I
could never, you know, get behind it because
of the level of the intensity of the stories.
Then I find Japanese animation and it's
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
It's the real deal.
>>Mark: it's insane.
It's insane.
I'm all "Supernatural Beasty City, are you
kiddin' me?
This thing's insane.
Ninja Scroll?
These guys are nuts.
Akira?
Oh my God."
So that was what I really appreciated about
Japanese animation is that in that culture,
animation isn't just for kids.
It's for everybody.
Right?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: It's an art form that you can tell
any story in.
And the different levels of intensity of the
story and the film-making behind those, to
create that intensity was right up my alley.
>>Male Presenter: But it, maybe it, was it
important you actually saw that as a kid?
So I mean, did that impact the way you thought
of children's entertainment?
Or what children are capable of enjoying?
Or?
>>Mark: Totally.
I mean, I think that.
My littlest kid, he's six now.
Ford.
I have four children.
I have a daughter and three boys just like
Fergus in the movie.
But he is kinda grown up with his older brothers
and sisters.
So he watches like, Ghost Rider and Wrath
of the Titans and, you know.
He's watching these movies and he'll turn
to me and I'm all "Whaddyou think, Ford?"
And he's all, "It's alright."
>>Male Presenter: [laughs]
>>Mark: you know, PG-13 movies.
But every once in a while he'll regress, so
we'll get back home and he'll have me read
him "Hop on Pop".
You know, 'cause he needs a little bit of
that too just to balance.
>>Male Presenter: Pressure down.
Yeah.
A little bit of a kid.
>>Mark: Just to take it down a notch.
>>Male Presenter: Dr. Seuss is pretty cool.
>>Mark: Yeah.
Dr. Seuss is cool.
Just not violent.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
Well, ah
>>Mark: I mean, blood spraying, fine.
He's like, I didn't, they lacked the motivation.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: You know, and I'm all "OK, six year
old."
>>Male Presenter: I mean, it's a funny thing
in children's entertainment.
You know, there's like, Brothers Grimm and
>>Mark: Yes.
Pretty dark stuff.
>>Male Presenter: Historically.
>>Mark: Yeah.
Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: What is it about professional
storytellers that want to terrify children.
>>Mark: Well, I think it's good for them to
get terrified.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: I mean because that's what's comin'
down the pike.
You know.
I think we shelter our children too much.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: I think we shelter our children a
little too much.
'Cause we don't wanna deal with the crying
or whatever.
The nightmares and them getting out of bed
and sleeping in your bed.
So, I think what the Grimms and the folk tales
or Aesop's fables, they're saying "Look, we're
gonna put it in a form that you can digest.
But the lesson is real because when you grow
up, there's people out there that are gonna
hurt you, rob you, steal you, kill you, take
advantage of you.
And you need to be prepared so that you're
not naïve.
And there are real consequences out there
in the real world."
>>Male Presenter: It kind of shows in "Brave"
in a way, it's sort of an anti-princess story
in a way.
>>Mark: Absolutely.
From top to bottom, that's one thing that
we were doing.
Because, and, you know, bless Pixar for being
one of these companies that is pushing the
bounds of animation today.
>>Male Presenter: yeah.
>>Mark: That we can do something darker.
Because every Pixar movie there's an honesty
in it.
There's an honesty in the message.
There's an honesty in looking at the characters
and what they have to go through.
We don't have a lot of villains in Pixar movies.
It's the main characters, their own problem.
They have to get over their own self.
Just like we all have issues.
And there's something more real about that
and relatable, right?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
Definitely.
>>Mark: I don't have a nemesis in real life,
you know?
So, watching movies with a nemesis you're
just all "So what?" you know?
>>Male Presenter: It's too easy.
>>Mark: But for "Brave" we were telling that
darker tale and we were embracing that darker
tale because it's important.
This kid, Merida, she's a teenager.
She's on the cusp of adulthood.
She's at that transitionary spot.
I like to talk when we were making I referenced
Peter Pan all the time.
I said "It's Peter Pan with teeth."
Because that's that same story in Peter Pan.
It's Wendy's all, her biggest dilemma, she's
getting kicked out of the nursery.
Sleeping with her two brothers.
Boo-hoo.
But she goes on this journey and she realizes
"Oh yeah, these guys are childish and idiots
and stuff and I'm above.
I'm ready for more.
I am an adult".
Merida has to go on the same journey but in
a more hard-hitting way.
>>Male Presenter: So I wanna talk a little
bit about the star of the movie.
>>Mark: Uh-huh.
>>Male Presenter: Which is definitely Merida's
hair.
>>Mark: Uh-huh
>>Male Presenter: Tell me, I wanna know a
little bit about the animation that went into
that.
And the sort of symbolism of hair in this
film that seems to be there.
Give me your thinking about that.
>>Mark: Well, you know, movie making is a
visual story telling medium.
And everything that we do supports the story.
The design of the backgrounds, the design
of the castle, I mean, what we're trying to
say about the land.
About the characters.
It's all in the design.
And for Merida, right off the back we knew
she was gonna have this relationship with
her mother where they were at odds.
And if her mother is the queen, who's going
to be regal and noble and wear these long
flowing gowns that are bejeweled and a crown
and this long hair that's tied up in a braid
and she's very much in control, what's the
direct opposite of that?
That's the rough hewn dress that looks like
it's tearing open and ripping with the puffy
sleeves.
And this mass of curly, unbridled wild hair.
You know.
It just had to be red.
Because she's passionate and fierce and independent.
So that as soon as she walks out on-screen
you know exactly what her story is.
Without the filmmakers having to go into any
exposition to see what her character is like.
And everything that she does reinforces her
look.
She's spirited, she'll talk back, she does
things her own way.
She doesn't make any excuses.
And she doesn't compromise so we can have
fun with this character and really get behind
her and get behind that look.
And it's really iconic and dynamic as much
as she is.
>>Male Presenter: So I saw the extra clips
in "The Incredibles" and in that you have
very closely cropped hair.
Maybe more like Marine style.
>>Mark: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Now you're growing your
locks a bit.
What does your hairstyle tell about your character.
>>Mark: Well, you know, since it takes place
in the middle ages, I just wanted to grow
my hair out.
To just kind of grow it out and be in the
spirit of the movie.
I instituted, when I came on board to direct,
"Kilt Fridays" So everybody started buying
up kilts and we wore our kilts every Friday.
At work.
So it's just to motivate.
And, 'cause we know we're workin' on somethin'.
Everybody's been workin' on it for a long
time.
To kind of keep that passion and energy goin'
'cause it ain't done yet.
You kind of go out of your way to kinda do
this things to kinda pick up the energy and
things.
Because we knew we had something very special
with this movie.
And everybody who's working on it really dug
it.
Knew they were workin' on something special
and workin' on something kind of new.
And we're pushing the boundaries on what we've
done before.
'Cause we've had hair.
We've had cloth.
And simulators and stuff.
We've just never had this much before.
To the levels that we're doing.
I mean even the backgrounds with our effects
team was amazing.
The stuff that they had to do in the movie
that's pretty much invisible.
Rain and water and the fires.
Hard as hell to do.
I mean, there's lots of organics to sell this
kinda time period and place.
And that's everything that the computer hates.
The computer hates organics.
It wants straight clean Tron-like lines.
You know?
>>Male Presenter: So Google's kind of a nerdy
company.
Lots of engineers.
I heard another interviewer speaking about,
you guys rewrote almost the entire software
after this for the cycle.
What went into that?
>>Mark: Yeah.
Yeah.
It was 25 years old, right?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: We don't even have cars that are 25
years old
>>Male Presenter: [chuckles]
>>Mark: without hefty overhaul.
So it was time at the studio they decided
we needed to revamp the system and kind of
create it anew.
And give us all these more powerful tools
and stuff like that.
So, but when do you do it?
We gotta make a movie?
Right?
We gotta use this software.
So "Brave" kind of got assigned to do that.
And everybody said "Yeah.
OK.
Yeah let's do it."
Which kind of added to the development of
"Brave” because we're developing a software
system at the same time.
So that kind of made the movie in production
increased the length that it was in production.
To make up the stuff.
I mean the software just to do her hair was
two years to develop.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: The water.
So there's a scene where they're playing in
this river.
To do that scene it took a year just to do
the water effects for that scene.
>>Male Presenter: I'm sure, yeah.
>>Mark: It just took us a long time.
But there's lots of other stuff.
There's animation controls and things that
we did with rigging.
We had to rewrite the software that we had
for her hair, to create the hair.
Just create the hair.
And then we had to have a whole new software
package to move the hair.
And simulate the hair.
That went into the dresses and the clothes
and stuff .And if you looked at "The Incredibles,"
the first time that we're really doing humans
throughout the movie.
We had hair, and we had cloth sims.
And they were wrestling matches to do it.
And that was just a "super suit".
That was nothing.
It was one layer.
And Violet had that long straight hair.
And then Merida has all this big curly locks
and everybody's go seven layers of clothing
on.
Fergus has got seven layers on.
That's all simmed.
And it's all talking to each other and stuff,
and reacting to each other.
So we've come a long way since "Incredibles."
>>Male Presenter: So I mean, it seems that
story is the, sort of, sort of leads the way
at Pixar.
Which is I think why your movies are so incredible.
>>Mark: um-hum.
>>Male Presenter: have there been times you
tell the engineers you wanna do something
and they curse at you and kick and scream?
I mean, what's the example
>>Mark: [laughs] Right.
>>Male Presenter: of where they told you like,
you're insane.
Do they have to take a walk and suck it up
or is it something that they actually can
win a battle or two?
>>Mark: They never say "No."
Because they like the challenge, too.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: I mean, who wants to work on the same
old thing all the time.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: That's one thing I really like about
Pixar as a company is that they never wanna
plateau.
They never wanna be comfortable.
As soon as they get comfortable and they get
complacent, we're not gonna be doing good
movies at all.
So we constantly wanna push it.
And the technology is always driven by the
story.
So we show up and we go "We wanna do this
thing in Scotland with hair and kilts!"
They're all, and they go "OK.
How do we do that?" and they go over hear
and talk.
I'll be in the room and I'll say "I want wolves!"
and I walk out.
And they'll be all "How do we do wolves?"
[mumbling] And they start talkin' and drawing
diagrams and math comes out.
Which is one reason I leave the room
>>Male Presenter: Sure.
>>Mark: and technical diagrams.
And we have physicists.
And all kinds of people that are workin' at
Pixar.
One of our SIM guys made a nanotube radio.
At Berkeley.
That's what he did before coming to work.
I'm all "How does this compare?"
He's all "This is so much more fun!"
I'm all "OK."
Just makin' things go, you know, like this.
But they love the challenge and they go for
it and they'll come back and say "We can't
do it.
We can't do that.
But we got this other thing."
And then you find ways of getting what you
want.
But they usually don't say, throw down their
fists and pound the table and get upset.
They're like "How do we do that?"
>>Male Presenter: They know you're a sword
fighter.
>>Mark: Yes.
Yeah.
I'm super intimidating.
At work.
>>Male Presenter: [laughs] Yeah.
You mentioned Kilt Friday's.
And other ways you try to keep the crew motivated.
You know it's' a very long development cycle
for a film, compared to what we work on
>>Mark: It can be.
Yeah.
Sure.
>>Male Presenter: at Google.
So, you know, how do you sustain the excitement
years in, you know?
To keep people motivated and fresh.
>>Mark: Right.
>>Male Presenter: 'Cause when it comes out
it seems like, you know, there's a beautifully
crafted thing.
And you don't get a sense of the labor.
>>Mark: Right.
And you shouldn't.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: But, it's just, I think, I mean for
me, I like the challenge.
And I like the problem solving aspect of story.
You know, how do you take an idea or develop
an idea from scratch and get an audience to
care about it and emote and react to it?
And there's a billion and one ways to skin
a cat.
There's so many potential ways to go on a
movie to show off a character or to describe
this bit of information.
But what's the right way?
So that everything falls in line and the audience
is with you.
You know?
And this crying or laughing or on the edge
of their seats.
So I love that problem.
And I think everybody at Pixar kinda has that
fascination to solving the problem.
You know?
And especially when we have these stories
that we ourselves dig and we're fans of.
We're our harshest critics at Pixar.
We put up the movie and storyboard reels and
we watch it.
Everybody together.
And we go "That totally blew.
What did we do wrong?" and we tear it down
and we do it again.
And we do this constantly.
Look at it because one of the lessons we learn
is that the proof is in the pudding.
So you can talk about it all you want of what
the scene should be or what the story should
be or the direction you should go.
But until you actually see it playing in time
in context, with everything involved working,
or not working, that's when you know.
I mean, you guys all see movies right?
You guys all see movies?
How many people saw a sucky movie recently.
>>Male Presenter: [chuckles]
>>Mark: What do you see after you see a sucky
movie?
>>Male Presenter: Gripe about it.
>>Mark: You gripe about it.
And you talk about what they should have done,
right?
That they dropped the ball or it wasn't invested
or it wasn't interested.
That's what we do all day.
That's my job.
Is to make a movie, a sucky movie.
Look at it, and then gripe about it.
Say "Man, they didn't have any motivation.
That character was totally pointless in the
movie.
Why did they go here, they should have gone
here.
Hooooooo."
And then take it down and do it again and
stick it up and go "Less sucky.
But still the ending I'm not.
I don't care."
And then you take it back and put it back
up and that's what we do.
>>Male Presenter: You mentioned all the details
that go into the Pixar films.
And I just wanna say that they're appreciated.
Like it's really wonderful to see so many
things put together.
And you know, the one of the triplets lip-synching
to the story is awesome.
'Cause the triplets don't speak in the whole
film, but that's the one time they get to
speak
>>Mark: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: and it's just, there's so
many terrific moments like that.
I'm looking forward to seeing it.
Seeing it several times actually.
You mentioned, I've heard you say a few times
that story is hell.
>>Mark: Yep.
>>Male Presenter: Why is story so hard.
>>Mark: It's the 666th layer of the abyss.
>>Male Presenter: [laughs]
>>Mark: Because you can't pin it down.
Because there's so many possibilities.
And what's the right possibility?
And we kind of go into it intellectually,
of what we need it to be about these characters.
And their purpose.
And how do we get the information to the audience?
You know.
In an economic and clear kinda way so that
they get all these ideas and the themes and
they have an experience.
That's a tall order.
And it's trial and error.
I mean the, I teach, too.
I teach visual story telling and storyboarding.
And my students are always asking me for the
silver bullet.
"What's the silver bullet?
What's the silver bullet?
What's the secret?"
I'm all, "The secret is just a lot of hard
work.
It's banging your head against the concrete
until you make a hole in the wall and you
can go through."
Is basically what it is.
You just have to try stuff on for size and
see that it doesn't work and try it again
and try it again and try it again.
Michelangelo talked about looking at the big
thing, square of marble and seeing the inside.
We don't know what it is.
We don't know what it is on the inside.
We start chippin' at marble and then we ruin
that entire piece of marble going "I don't
want David.
I want.
Oh, now I know what I want!"
And we'd start on another piece of marble.
I like to refer to it as alchemy.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Mark: We're changing lead to gold.
And as soon as we have gold, we go "Haha!
Yes!
How did we do that?
I don't remember.
" I have no idea what the formula was.
And we can't replicate that formula so every
time we go into another movie it's a new set
of problems.
It's a new set of variables.
And it's different every time.
I mean, there are.
You have all these experiences from making
the movies.
I have my executive producers John Lasseter,
Andrew Stanton and Pete Docter.
And they're walkin' around with their Academy
Awards.
They bring 'em into the office and say "Knk.
OK, you're gonna do it this way buddy."
They don't do that.
[laughter]
But they have all this experience so they
kind of know where the pitfalls are, before
you get there.
But they also don't have all the answers either.
[snapping] Or else these films would not take
the time that it takes to do them and we'd
be out the door.
With five films a year.
No problem.
But everything it's difficult.
It's really, really, really difficult.
>>Male Presenter: Do you ever worry that the
seams are gonna show?
I mean is that a fear for you that a movie
is gonna come out and people are gonna, you
know.
>>Mark: Oh yeah.
There's tons of stuff in here that the seams
are showing.
And I'm just goin' [chomps teeth] You know?
Is anybody in the audience gonna notice?
Because again, we're our own harshest critics.
We know what's half-baked.
>>Male Presenter: Sure
>>Mark: And what's not fully cooked.
There's that scene in "Tucker", the movie
"Tucker" where they present the car.
To show it off.
But it doesn't have an engine on it and it
can't even move?
That's kinda how we feel sometimes.
Because it's not, you can still work on it.
Or is that the best solution I have for that
moment?
Or to tell that story or that part of the
story?
'Cause there could have been something just
around the corner.
>>Male Presenter: Right.
>>Mark: and that's the other thing.
I like working in the parameters.
>>Male Presenter: Sure.
>>Mark: And that's what I learned from TV,
is that, if you don't have time, you kinda
get more creative and what really happens
is you get more objective.
>>Male Presenter: yeah.
>>Mark: So you're willing to kill your babies
faster.
'Cause you make a baby and then you kill it,
'cause that's not, you didn't want that one.
I know, it's a violent process.
Stories are a violent process.
>>Male Presenter: We've done that at Google
doodle where you have the letters and we "kill
babies" all the time.
>>Mark: Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You're going "No.
No."
I mean, when I used to work on paper, I wouldn't
even bother when I did a drawing, I wouldn't
even bother putting it in the trashcan.
I'd be working so fast, it'd be "No.
No.
Oooo that's interesting.
Save.
No.
No."
And you come into my room and it's wall to
wall drawings.
The animators would come in and pick through
the drawings of these rough half-baked ideas
and steal them and go away.
Every once in a while, every three months,
I could literally roll up my floor.
I start at one corner, because they're all
interlaced, all these pieces of paper.
And I just start rollin' it up.
And I walk out with this six foot roll of
storyboards and dump it in the trash.
But it's that.
It's being objective.
It's finding the thing.
The kernel of an idea that I get excited about
as an audience.
I have to be the audience.
And go "Oo!
Oo!
I love that!
What does this mean?
I don't know yet, but it's something."
And then I'll figure out how to put it in.
>>Male Presenter: And then so years of effort,
many six foot tubes of drawings
>>Mark: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: A film comes out.
What does success mean to you?
How do you feel like, a job well done?
I mean, you've been part of so many incredible
films.
>>Mark: Right.
I think, when we have our wrap party.
And the crew is seeing it finished.
Totally completed.
And they're laughing and crying and on the
edges of their seats.
Because they're the harshest critics, you
know?
And they come up to me and say "I love the
movie, Oh my gosh, that was so great!"
They could be lyin' in my face.
But I hope they're not.
And so when they said "I love the movie, oh
my gosh it was so good."
When I have Brad Bird goin', "Mark.
No.
Really."
You know, then I've done my job.
When John's sittin' there going "Ah-ahahahahahah!"
and tears are in his eyes
[laughter]
A multi Academy award winner.
I'm done.
I've done my job and I'm ready to get on to
the next one.
If it comes out and it doesn't make a dime,
I don’t care.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
I cried on, I'm gonna admit to you I cried.
But I hedged my bets because my girlfriend
was sitting next to me.
>>Mark: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: And I sort of tilted my
head so the tear, it was more of like a single
tear running down the side.
And she was on the, she
>>Mark: She didn't see it?
>>Male Presenter: She heard me sniffling.
She's like "Oh, are you crying."
And I'm like.
And I could do this sort of like, you know.
[laughter]
>>Mark: Like, right.
Right.
With your drink.
[slurps]
>>Male Presenter: Right.
Use like a straw, like [slurps] Suck it up.
But I think the movie is gonna be a big success
because it's terrific.
>>Mark: right.
Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: Again, thanks so much.
I think now we can open up for questions.
I've satisfied my immediate curiosities and
anybody in the audience might also have some?
There's some questions online that we can
ask as well.
>>Mark: Well.
Sure.
>>male #1: Alright, my name's Tyler.
So coming from the perspective of a storyteller,
animator and storyboarder, how do you adjust
that when it comes to 3D.
Now that 3D is an aspect.
Does that have an effect on the story at all?
>>Mark: Yeah, and that's a great question.
3D is just another visual tool right?
When I saw, I don't like 3D particularly because
I think there's weird things happening with
my eyeballs, 'cause I'm already seeing depth,
and then you're putting this kinda fake depth
on there.
But when I saw Avatar, 'cause James Cameron,
love James Cameron and he loves 3D.
And I'm going "Why does he love 3D?"
When I see Avatar, what he was doing with
the 3D, I'm pullin' off my glasses goin' "There's
no 3D in this scene.
Oh, there's 3D.
Oh, there's no 3D here."
He's using it as a tool to help tell the story.
He's using it to impact the experience.
The emotional ride.
The, you know, when there's a lot of depth
because the character is going through some
intensive moment, he cranks up the 3D.
And when it's just talking heads he doesn't.
Or when there's lots of things crossing, to
enhance that visual space.
He's using it as a tool like I use color or
the camera move or editing or design.
These are all visual tools to help tell a
story.
So that when we were doing 3D on this, with
Bob Whitehill, our stereo-, stereog-, [garbles]
guy.
See, the no school.
[laughter]
Art school.
>>Male Presenter: same here.
>>Mark: Our stereographer.
I would always, we'd look at the pieces like
"OK, OK.
Here I want almost zero depth.
Because it's not dynamic.
Here she is riding through the forest, we're
totally dyna-, I want all the depth you can
give me."
And dialing in and out of that.
So it blooms.
'Cause if it's 3D all the time, and depth
all the time.
Then what is that statement to the viewer?
That would be like listening to something
on absolute loud all the time.
And there has to be variation and rhythms
just like there's variation and rhythms in
the storytelling.
So the visuals have to support the story.
So 3D is just another tool to help do that.
That's how I'm usin' it, anyway.
You're not gonna catch the same thing on "Clash
of Titans" or anything like that.
Yes!
>>female #1: Hi, I have a couple questions
that were submitted over the internet.
And they're similar so I'll read em together.
Pablo from Vancouver says "Hi, as a screenwriting
student I would like to know how the writing
process of 'Brave' was.
I see four people have screenwriting credits.
Did it change when you joined as director?"
and also Connor from Sicklerville, New Jersey
wants to know how much did the story change
since its original conception in 2008.
>>Mark: Great.
Good questions.
Uhhhhh.
How did the story change?
The bones has always been the same of the
story.
Brenda Chapman, my fellow director, who started
the project, it was her original idea and
concept.
That was based off of her experience as a
parent with her six year old daughter who's
this very feisty, spirited, willful, talkback
child at six.
So she kind of projected ahead to when her
daughter was going to be a teenager.
And kinda went "Oh my God, what is this gonna
be like?"
So it was that kind of core relationship of
that parent and child during these very transitional
time period as a teenager, was always at the
heart of the story.
Setting in Scotland was always at the heart
of the story.
And this magic that was going to happen in
the story.
I don't wanna ruin it for anybody as you'll
see in the movie.
We're keepin' the secrets.
Was always part of the story.
And like I was talking about before.
How exactly do you tell that story?
You go in and out and you try different things.
There was this, there was competing characters
at one time.
Merida, mom and dad were kind of competing
for Merida in a sense.
Is Merida gonna be more like her dad Fergus,
or is Merida gonna be more like her mother?
And they were kinda pulling her attentions
And those types of things.
So when I came on, what I did was there was
this kind of like 18 month deadline.
And
>>Male Presenter: Wow.
>>Mark: The story wasn't going.
It wasn't where it needed to be at 18 months
before we released.
So and this had happened before on "Ratatouille"
on "Toy Story II".
We've had director changes at Pixar before.
And Pixar will do whatever is necessary to
tell that great story.
Whether it's push back the release date, or
unfortunately, have a director change.
So Pixar asked me to jump on board, to take
over directing on "Brave" and so what I did
is, I looked at it as an adaptation.
I'd just come off of adapting "John Carter
of Mars" And writing that with Andrew.
So I looked at it as an adaption where there's
thing that definitely worked in the story
and things that didn't.
So clearing those out kind of left spaces.
And I can do that coming in and being objective.
Because it wasn't mine.
I didn't create it.
So that left holes.
You know, to go to the comment about the script
writing.
There were still elements of the script that
were kept and then I wrote the script with
Steve Purcell who was the original co-director
with Brenda.
So there was a continuity there.
But we would rewrite the script.
On lots of scenes.
Mordu, that whole element came up.
What exactly the magic was and how it worked
changed.
And the main thing I did was made it just
Merida's story.
Just made it about the teenager so I could
have that straight through line.
And kinda clean up the balance of the story.
Because there was a lot of characters drawing
the balance away from the main conflict.
So the screenwriting process is again, it's
trial and error.
I write, I pass it out to the storyboard guys.
They visualize it.
So they story board it and put it up.
And then we look at the scene and I go "No,
no, no, no.
This doesn't work.
Let's try this that and the other thing.
" They do the notes, I put it in editorial.
We watch it as it's timed and edited.
I'm going "You know that line doesn't work
and da, da, da."
And you constantly are in this state of evolution
and changing it.
>>Male Presenter: Those are, the creation,
but those are big changes.
Top down.
Director changes.
What about the kinda bottom up changes, like
you know, gags that come in from the story
artists.
>>Mark: Right, Right.
>>Male Presenter: Does that ever turn into
like a dramatic shift in the story?
Or like a tone in the scene?
Or?
How does that go down.
>>Mark: Sure.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
'Cause we're constantly looking for what the
entertainment is.
Of this scene.
So is there a chance to make it funny?
Or, or, or, it's not really working.
Well, because the action of the situation
isn't entertaining.
So let's change the action of the situation.
Oh my gosh!
It's totally entertaining.
I can't use this one.
Oh, yes I can.
So there's this one idea that we had where
Mom is griping to Fergus about her daughter.
>>Male Presenter: Sure.
>>Mark: Right.
'Cause the parents always talk about the kids
right, when the kids are away or in bed.
We always talk about
>>Male Presenter: I know where you're going
with this.
This is a cool thing.
>>Mark: Yeah.
And Merida had her own scene where she's griping
and worried about her future of this getting
married and being pushed into this.
And they were two separate scenes.
And we knew we had to have this information.
'Cause we need to get behind the Mom and we
need to understand what Merida's fears were
and her concerns about losing herself.
But they were two separate scenes and they
had been for a while.
And it was this huge road bump.
Like how do we get, they're not working.
But the information is right.
We have to have this information.
So we're arguing about it in the story room.
Me and the story guys.
Just hammering on it and hammering on it and
hammering on it.
I'm going "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a
minute."
'Cause somebody goes "Well, if they just talk
to each other, the movie would be over.
>>Male Presenter: [chuckles] That's true.
>>Mark: And I'm all "Why don't we have em
talk to each other?
" And they're all "What?"
I'm all "Let's have 'em talk to each other."
They're like "What are you talkin' about?"
And I'm all "Listen."
And then I pitched them the scene in the movie
where Eleanor, the queen, is talking to Fergus,
as if Fergus was Merida and Merida is talking
to her horse, as if the horse was Eleanor.
But I intercut that conversation so they're
talking to each other.
And it instantly made it super entertaining.
And we got all the information out in this
very economical way.
Those things happen all the time.
Right?
And that's that gold when you find it.
You're all "Bingo!
Voom!
Done!' and when everybody saw it they're all
"Whoo-hoo!"
>>Male Presenter: yeah.
Awesome.
>>Mark: I hope that answers your questions
internet guys.
[laughter]
>>male #2: Hi.
Every few years there seems to be either a
trend or a breakthrough in effects that centers
around a certain technology.
Like 10, 15 years ago, it was cloth and hair.
And then crowd simulations.
What a digital and compositing and particle
systems.
VOX.
And all these kinda things.
And it sounds like you rewrote everything
for Brave.
What would you say the next challenge or trend
is?
In, or, big challenge for animators?
Especially around effects.
>>Mark: Right.
Right.
>>male#2: What's the most difficult thing
that people are trying to attack right now?
>>Mark: Right.
Well that's a great question.
I know that we're working on lighting right
now.
Real interactive high speed lighting.
So that, 'cause in animation I can't just
put, we turn on these lights, they hit me
they're hittin' you.
They're bouncin' across the floor.
The bounce light from the floor is hittin'
the chairs.
It's lighting the chairs.
We've got the sunlight comin' in from there.
I mean everything's splashing around and doing
stuff for free.
We don't need to do anything in real life.
In animation, that's its own light.
And what it's doing to me, I have to have
another light and what it's doing to the wall,
I have to assign a quality to that wall so
that it operates the way that this paint should
versus the carpet.
You know all that stuff.
So what they're tryin' to do right now is
develop, like real light source reacting.
So that everybody already has assigned things
so when the computer turns on the light in
the virtual world, it's go, "Oh, plastic.
Chair.
Carpet.
Skin.
Levi's.
Watch.
Reflective surface.”
All that kinda stuff.
And you kinda get it for free.
So we don't have to manipulate and put all
these little lights.
These invisible lights all over the place.
So I know they're working on that.
But that is just a small step to get towards
the bigger step which is context.
Right?
Animation is movie making in slow motion.
Because we're constantly building the context.
We get nothing for free.
So what they're trying to do is, when the
animators get it, it looks like done.
And can animate done.
With the lights done.
And the set done.
So we could look at it, constantly in context.
So I think that is the next big step.
>>male #2: So you mean like animating in a
real time render.
>>Mark: animating in a real time render.
And there's some gaming companies that are
kind of doing this already with their game
engines.
They're makin movies or cinematics in the
game that they built.
I saw "Half Life II", I'm all "Whoooooooooaaaa".
I mean, the things and my guns shooting and
it's moving stuff on the walls and it's interactive
and it's real.
It's real time.
I'm all "We can make a movie in this!"
People are actually doing that.
They'll play the zombie game and they'll have
one guy out there zipping zombies with their
cheated bazooka gun while the crew is inside
actually shooting on the set.
It's crazy.
They're using the game engines so they can
bring in the animation and have the guys stand
around and that.
And they have to go back and touch, for lip
synch and things like that.
But they can more the camera around and they
shoot coverage and things and they're on the
walkie talkies "OK, I'm comin' in now.
Get ready.
And, action!" and they do all the stuff just
like you do.
So that's fantastic.
And that's the kinda stuff that I wanna do.
You know, using motion capture to get to those
answers quicker.
Right?
Because we can go down so many paths.
When I was shooting live action on "John Carter"
we had spontaneity like this [snaps] all the
time.
I could tell Taylor Kitch or Earlan Collins.
"No no, no, no.
Come in different.
Even more frazzled and harried.
This is, life is on the line.
Come in you're totally defeated.
Now, lone kid.
That, that's' good.
I got that one, come in totally defeated."
And you're finding the scene in the context.
In animation we have to [chuckles] build the
context and then find the scene as we're goin'
along.
We have to put in the serendipity.
So any camera shake or out of focus things
that you see in an animated film isn't a mistake.
I wanted it in there to give it that organic
feel.
So I think the next big technological feat
is we're gonna be making animated films in
context.
>>male #2: Do you think that's gonna shorten
the amount of time it takes to make an animated
film, or just give you more
>>Mark: You would think that it would.
But it's probably not.
[laughter]
Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: Thank you.
It, follow up on that.
If story is really the most important thing.
>>Mark: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: and you can tell a story
with stick figures.
>>Mark: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: Why spend ungodly some of
money and years to get the type of realism
and the type of wall you need?
>>Mark: Because the stick figures, it would
have to be a really, really, really, really,
really fantastic story to get carried away
with stick figures.
>>Male Presenter: sure.
>>Mark: I don't think a story exists that
can get you carried away with stick figures.
We're compelled by what we're watching.
And we wanna be transported.
So, which is why, I mean, they have motion
pictures.
You know and they get a camera out there.
And we could emote with these real life people
on experiences we don't normally have.
I mean there are things that work.
I mean you watch the old Peanuts things and
old cartoon things.
And you're feeling of these things that are
very simple.
But that can only go so far.
So when we're makin' movies.
When we're sketching.
That's just a rough idea to, because I'm projecting
ahead.
With what it's going to look like.
And that, once the audience finally sees it
all done and lit and everything like that,
they're transported to that place.
To that world.
With these characters.
You know, and they're really living it.
Yes,sir.
>>female #1: we just have time for one more
question and that will be Justin.
>>Male #3: So I saw the Japanese trailer for
"Brave" on YouTube.
And the impression one gets of the movie is
a lot darker and more mystical and consequently
more interesting than the American trailer
gives.
And so, it's just seems unfortunate with all
of Pixar's success in making animated features
that appeal to adults they still have to be
marketed to kids.
Do you see any indication that that's changing
over time or will change?
Down the road?
>>Mark: Oh yeah.
I think so.
I mean the Japanese audience is a very different
audience than the American audience.
Just like the Russians are very different.
And the French, you see the French things,
it's crazy.
You know, the Norwegians are very different.
So the marketing people have a challenge to
how do I take this one movie and give it these
different guises to appeal to all those different
markets.
To get their butts in the chairs.
'Cause that's what they need to do.
We need the awareness.
We need to get the butts in the chairs so
they can see it.
Spend their moolah.
Gonna love it.
Hopefully see it again.
Spend more moolah.
So we can keep making movies.
I think, so the reason that our trailers are
done here the way they are is pretty much,
is what the audience wants.
And it's what they react to.
And it's again, it's this weird alchemy of
predicting what the audience needs.
I've been doing a lot of PR during my, I'm
here with you guys today.
But to talk more about the movie.
But one thing that I keep getting from journalists
is they're very impressed with how much, after
they've seen the movie, how much of the movie
is not in any trailer.
How much we're keeping stuff, we're withholding
things and keeping it a secret.
And I really have to give our Disney marketing
teams and Pixar for wanting to do that a lot
of props.
Because I wanna give the audience a ride.
I wanna give them an experience.
And be like telling your kid on Christmas
"Here, I gotcha that thing that you wanted.
The Lego Death Star.
Go ahead and unwrap it."
They'd be like [pause] "Yeah, it's a Lego
Death Star.
Thanks.
I wanted to unwrap it and find it and discover
it."
And that's what a movie is.
When you go in, you should know just enough
to have gotten you in the seat.
And then not know what to expect beyond that.
That it could go anywhere.
And I think a lot of trailers today, all over
the world, for all kinds audiences.
Especially for American audiences.
They say everything about the movie.
You know?
You get the beginning middle and end.
You're just goin' [slaps knees].
You know, and if it's a comedy, forget it.
Because you saw all the most funny parts.
So when you go and see the movie you're all
"Well, I saw all the funny parts in the trailer.
What's left?
This?
Pfff.
Why'd I come see this?
I thought there was gonna be more."
So by withholding that information in a trailer,
especially in the "Brave" trailer, you know,
it's giving the audience that.
I think that is the first step, to go to your
question, that's the first step in kind of
pushing that boundary of trusting the filmmakers
and the film that they're gonna put out there.
That an audience doesn't need much.
I mean, I was ready to see "Prometheus", I
didn't need to see any, hear any talking at
all.
Just those images, I was captivated.
You know?
And that's the kinda thing that gets me.
And I think the more audiences respond to
that, then the feedback and the pie charts
will come back to the marketing folks and
they'll go, "Oh yeah, these things were hits.
It got them into the theaters to see this
movie with less."
So I'm a big believer of less is more.
So that you the audience have the more when
you see the movie.
>>Male Presenter: So without adding any more.
>>Mark: Without adding anymore.
>>Male Presenter: Do yourselves a favor and
go unwrap the gift that is "Brave", it's an
awesome movie.
And thank you so much for joining us.
>>Mark: My pleasure.
>>Male Presenter: and hope to have you back
next time you make one of your movies.
>>Mark: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
See ya online guys!!
[applause]
>>Mark: thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
>>Male Presenter: My pleasure.